oh leslie leslie welcome welcome welcome
i
have a lot of bottles there oh yeah
would you like a vitamin b12
evening primrose oil willow bark
magnesium no thank you sure
really good for hangovers okay i'll take
one i take care of my body
above all else diet exercise supplements
positive thinking
scientists believe that the first human
being who will live 150 years has
already been born
i believe i am that human being
you wanted to see me good god what the
hell are you doing
upside down sit-ups great exercise and
it literally lets me see the world from
a different perspective
isn't there a men's gymnasium where you
could do that
the world's my gymnasium wrong but i
will stop it makes you feel
uncomfortable
could you hold me while i dismount
thanks so much leslie i have loved
your book i read it cover to cover wow i
just gave it to you an hour ago
i'm a speed reader i can read over 3000
words a minute with total comprehension
one time i read all of siddhartha at a
traffic stop
pawnee's most notorious businessman in
the building i brought some
entertainment 720 pillowcases for your
pillow
never stop dreaming tom haverford
i never do chris traeger respect game
recognized game
again perkins hey how was your run
ended with a five and a half minute mile
my personal low
i think the pavement in this town is
soft what's with the mask
flu prevention my body is finely tuned
like a microchip and the flu
is like a grain of sand it could
literally shut down the entire system
my body's like a chip too potato chip
no speaking of potato chips you and i
are on for dinner tomorrow yes
yes definitely i'm super super excited
looking forward to it excellent
way to go buddy way to go we've been on
a couple of dates
i really like him the problem is he's
like a
perfect human man i can't find
one flaw there was one time i thought he
farted
but it was me
dragonmeister you made it
yeah i got your email we need to talk
first off though try a little snake
juice
it's 140 proof which means it's 70 on
alcohol
but don't worry there's plenty of
caffeine in it to keep you awake i
believe
an ounce of that would literally kill me
hey ann what happened i just saw you a
few hours ago and you were fine
not like damn you're fine but fine
health-wise
my body has no fat to protect itself
from disease things happen very quickly
listen to me it's very important that
you replenish my body
with electrolytes after every
involuntary loss of bodily fluids
oh boy my body tends to lose a lot of
fluids
when it's sick my brain is on fire i'm
dying
well you definitely have the flu oh my
god
the microchip has been compromised you
seem like you could use a beer
let's get a beer well oh oh oh oh
don't keep him too long i need someone
to be here when i take my multivitamin
this choking hazard okay can we go
diabetes fight it
not quite but i like the energy are we
still rolling yep
diabetes okay can we take a break i
think that's a great idea i think we
almost have it and i am very excited at
that prospect i'll cancel my four
o'clock and my five o'clock
at my six o'clock appointments
i vomited somewhere in this room
i don't remember where though wait you
might want to check that drawer
stop pooping
you have to get up off the floor now as
far as my friends
nothing like a complete physical
breakdown to make a guy seem less
intimidating
i love the flu this is weird
we're on chris's couch yep we are and
i'm wearing his clothes
uh well well
sorry i keep myself very well hydrated
and my bladder is the size of a thimble
i urinate roughly 12 times a night
can i ask you a question why am i so
positive all the time
yes that's exactly the question
i was born with a blood disorder and my
parents were told that i had three weeks
to live
and here i still am some 2000
odd weeks later and
i have enjoyed every one of them
every time i cleanse i can literally
feel the toxins leaving my body i know i
feel so much healthier
i've still got a full week to go before
the broth stage
pre-broth is an amazing stage it's when
you're most alert
hey whatever happened to you and the
bionic man
chris he broke up with me but he did it
so nicely that i didn't even realize he
did it
i've done that to multiple men
well good news is this is just
tendonitis how is that good news
the other option was shoulder cancer
really no
look you exercise a lot you're in great
shape little things like this happen
with men of your age
you met with my age how old do you think
i am 42.
i am 44 and i plan to live to be 150.
okay so what's the cure get a time
machine go back to being 20.
dr heros you are literally the meanest
person i have ever met
so you're saying that i intimidated you
no not exactly come on talk more about
that tantric workshop
i went to i was so into you okay and you
basically turned me into a female
version of yourself and then you got
bored dating me because you were dating
yourself
huh i mean i was jogging i hate jogging
talking's amazing jogging is the worst
chris it's snowing outside
isn't that great you seem like you're in
a good mood actually
i am quite miserable i admire and
respect you and dragging you
through an ethics trial is filling me
with sadness i have
never felt so low well you're radiating
pure joy
i went to my herbalist and got two b12
shots and then i ate an unreasonable
amount of st john's wort
and my herbalist took this weird bee
pollen paste rubbed it around my gums
and now my mouth feels like a spaceship
this
is stressful and stress leads to
depression and if i don't maintain an
extremely high dosage of herbal remedies
i will get very depressed oh god
it's happening right now we are here
today to determine whether leslie knope
omg leslie i read that same article the
history
of the latter it's utterly fascinating
ben you're gonna love this
do you know that the original image of a
ladder is in a cave
in valencia spain drawn over ten
thousand years oh my god how about some
music
[Music]
it's amazing what is this
why does the cult call themselves the
reasonable lists
well they figure if people criticize
them it'll seem like they're attacking
something very reasonable
that's weirdly brilliant look there's
nothing to worry about they've said that
the world's gonna end 15 times
and the only bad thing that's ever
happened on any of those dates is
lance armstrong dumping cheryl crow that
was a tragic day hmm
live strong at any rate i think ben and
i should accompany you tonight oh
i don't think we have to do that no no i
insist these people
live on planet not brain i live on
planet.brand
brandon nuts are very helpful for your
colon it's fantastic yeah
i worked really hard i did every pair
that i could uh i didn't know what to do
with these i think they're gloves no no
no those are sports sandals
they're for adventure racing they
perfectly contour to the human foot and
the human foot
is the ultimate technology dude that is
the coolest
sentence i've ever heard somebody talk
somebody say my name
chris swivel what is jerry
you told me to say your name and you did
a great job superstar
someone else say something you look like
a freak swivel
april that is not a very good attitude i
will keep my eye on you
from my circular desk where i can see
everything tiny swivel
see how it works
come on come on come on leslie knope
hey chris wow is that new jogging shirt
it is it's an experimental fabric called
bumbleflex
it's made out of synthetic beeswings
it's cool anyway you're not supposed to
be here you're suspended
i totally understand that i'm just gonna
uh take my flash drive and i'll do some
work from home
and oh you're specifically prohibited
from doing your job oh i'm not gonna do
my job
i'm just gonna oversee the department
and check in on the parks and attend any
meetings that are required of the deputy
director presley go home
and give me the flash drive
this is the nasal spray give me the
flash drive
give me the nasal spray on three
one two two three
okay good now in two weeks lastly no
i'm much faster than you i have bubble
flex
you